during my stay I also got to visit a
specialized unit called the EOD which
stands for explosive ordnance disposal
if you've seen The Hurt Locker you know
what I'm talking about this is pretty
fascinating I'm in the EOD flight
this is a special unit that specializes
in taking out explosive devices blowing
them up is that correct yes sir so you
get to blow up stuff I do
that's very cool it is and your name is
a little hesitant to why are you headed
it well it's actually a tradition of
ours that if we are published in any
sort of media that we owe everyone who
sees it a round of beer or drinks or
beverages of some sort I mean if you
appear on camera or say hear or say your
name you owe all of your friends beer
whoever sees it what's your name again
Bradley client I couldn't hear you
Bradley Klein Bradley Klein yes sir hey
just look right in there
brevity fine okay that's a lot of beer
that is a lot of beers I don't envy you
this vehicle is awesome what is this
vehicle this is called an M ATV right we
refer to as Matt be this thing looks
like it eight-six Hummers for breakfast
you know that rich old ladies with
plastic surgery are gonna be driving
these in Beverly Hills any gear I'm
gonna be Miss America and this is gonna
pull up and in little old lady's gonna
get out wearing a lot of jewelry can i
buy one of these I want one of these
I'll see what I can do but I make no
promises your name again
Bradley Klein right there Bradley Klein
oh man how many beers is that now let's
tally them all that's an entire brewery
sir yeah please don't call me sir call
me ma'am kind of a show of some of the
ordinance items that we typically deal
with aircraft bombs there's a landmines
research these are modern era aircraft
bombs not quite modern they still can be
used because this looks like something
Wiley coyote tried to drop him
this is our robotic platform we use this
in place of a person this is controlled
remotely that's correct that was a
really stupid question I just asked but
it's the only way this work is if three
guys had to push it that would be really
stupid right so this thing actually can
deactivate the device race loaded again
okay hold on a second
I think it's sense is it dangerous yeah
that's right
that's right I'm packing some major
explosives the border this looks
suspicious it's a tool that we use to
perform procedures
okay that was the most vague answer yeah
that's a tool that we use to perform
procedures on devices even this thing is
like that's [ __ ]
this looks like a little bit of an S&M
kind of thing what is that that's just
for pinching nipples isn't it again
these are the keys to my barracks room
there now if you could go back to my
room and unlock it and just wait for me
I guess you must be tempted sometimes to
use this to rob a bank no no of course
not so easy but you won't do it because
it's against the law that's right
you're good American that's exactly when
your name is Bradley Klein here in the
world I might be paranoid but I get the
sense that this thing is watching me it
absolutely is this it's what this guy is
watching me right that's right look it's
checking me out hey hey I'm a person I'm
not a piece of needs
[Music]
gotcha please tell me these are the
little babies of this guy coming back i
think the mom is getting mad they were
being very nice to little Bom Bom
this is the greatest tool case in the
history of the world Oh are these
suction cups they are these are the
suction cups that go on a Windows then
Oh fantastic
okay these are stuck now this isn't
ironic thrill would you like to try it
just tell me when I've gone too far okay
understand that's it you're like this
looks like a ping pong table but I'm
assuming this is high-tech highly
classified exactly that's it but I can't
tell you about it
it's a ping pong table isn't it maybe
this is the bomb suit this is what the
operator will wear if he has to take
what we called manual approach would
this actually protect you that has saved
lots of lives actually in use okay I
should use this during my monologue you
should when a joke doesn't work uh-huh
it says if you've been hit with a bomb
that's exactly how it feels hmm I happen
to tell a lot of what I think are
awesome jokes tell me an awesome joke
you got one I do so you know what the
difference is between a guy in a tuxedo
on a bicycle and a bum on a tricycle I
do not a tiger giving you stateside now
say it worked
suit me up fellas
now comes the heavy part this is not the
heavy part yet okay that was my skin
ripping
so now I weigh an almost 100 pounds more
than I did before
correct this suit is called the chris
Christie surprisingly comfortable you're
probably used to people walking like
this but does anyone ever do this
[Music]
sike
[Music]
[Applause]
Bradlee climb wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]